the very first coaching insider in the
history of NFL Network NFL total axis
was that at the time the defensive
coordinator of the San Francisco 49ers I
fired up Niners cam for this man
in 2003 week 11 when the NFL Network
came on the air he is a Jim Mora good to
see you sir great to see you rich thanks
for having you bet then you are
representing in this first segment of
here the Honda inside a report let's get
let's get right to it here Jim the
number one ranked quarterback on your
draft board is Josh Rosen okay you did
not stutter I did not why do you think
people are thinking that you're
denigrating him I don't know rich you
know I think the interpretations of what
I said I've just been misconstrued you
know I look back at everything I've said
about Josh since I've known him and I
don't believe I've ever said anything
negative publicly I'm sure you know in
times of frustration like we all did on
a dink Josh but I think when I made the
statements I made it I was very clear I
was very concise
I was very complimentary of Josh I love
this young man I think he's great I
think he's a great player a great person
he's a great friend of my my kids you
know I love that my kids have me have
him as a friend it all started when I
said that if I were the Cleveland Browns
I would take Sam Donald over Josh Rosen
subsequent to saying that on the air i
text Josh and said him about to say that
I would take Sam Donald over you for the
Cleveland Browns and he didn't heed his
said thanks Jim not like thanks his
relief just thanks Jim thanks coach
thanks for giving me that because I want
to let you know we have that type of
relationship but people said all these
coaches taking a shot at him and then
when I talked about him had needed to be
intellectually stimulated people took it
the wrong way unfortunately and I'm in
in a very positive way I've had now six
years with what I am referring to as
Millennials these kids in this you know
this age group where they need
intellectual stimulation you know they
can't stay locked in forever they're you
know constantly on their phones you're
seeing more and more coaches now that'll
give players even at the NFL level after
half hour a break to check their Twitter
and check all their their social media
and I think that you have to adapt how
you teach to the
way these kids learn and that's all that
I was saying and people just took it
chopped it up to make it fit their story
I should have known that and of all of
that I think the thing that I regret and
there's really only one thing I regret
because I stand by everything I said and
I will go to the grave sin I was never
negative about Josh is that it caused
some disruption in his life in his
preparation you know and he told me this
because we were in contact all the time
he said you know it just it's been hard
because the media has been bothering me
ask me why my coach doesn't like me I've
had some coaches call me saying hey
what's you know why is your coach saying
these things about you and I wish
everyone had listened to the whole thing
well then let's get into the whole thing
then okay cuz I have obviously the quote
right here but that's just part of the
quote you've got okay so then well I
mean you said he need the quote from
this in the Peter King mm QB he needs to
be challenged intellectually so he
doesn't get bored right so went but that
in itself it sounds like he he he isn't
going to apply himself yeah I can
understand that right when you say it
that way rich it makes sense but look
you have three young children I didn't
and as they get older and they get into
that age where this this phone and the
instant access to information becomes so
important in their life you're gonna see
that they needs to be caught they need
constant stimulation it's the way that
our world has gone and so every player
needs that exact same thing not just
Josh but this isn't as you know he is
incredibly intelligent he wants to be
challenged he wants to be a guy that has
high demands put on him he has high
standards for himself he he was great to
coach and he was never condescending I
made the comedy if you can tell him why
he would ask why it was never why it was
like why so I understand it better so I
can go out and perform better if you
told Josh hey you know throw a slant
he'd said he wanted on the front pad or
the back pad you know not so we're
talking inches so this is a type of
young man that a team is getting if they
draft him I say this about all these
young players and especially
quarterbacks is they have to understand
that the NFL is a different level and
ever been at well I think having him
being in the seat that you're you're in
right now just what is that about a
month ago now right that that I could
say he's gonna be a guy that wants to
get the playbook immediately yeah he's a
guy that's gonna want to take over the
quarterback room immediately he but you
know in his ESPN article he said that he
wants to have more rings than Ben Brady
which is an interesting way of saying
because I think he's maybe not going
overboard to show everybody how
committed he is you also said though
that if you can hold his concentration
level and focus only on football for a
few years he will set the world on fire
and then you did say is it so much Billy
and he's a really good kid which
obviously we're not going to talk about
that part of it but yeah but this guitar
to stay with the controversy because
again for somebody who has been in a
room seeing what his concentration level
is being with coaches that you have
hired to make sure that he does have
that concentration level it's jarring
hear that that he might not have that
and that he needs quote unquote to get
it whereas others that might be
available in the draft don't see I think
that's I believe I what you're saying
makes sense okay but once again Peter
decided what he wanted to write out of a
half-hour conversation
alright so josh is like every kid
alright listen there was a great article
I thought that vindicated me last week
in USA Today okay by Matt Jones and they
talked to Sean McVeigh who I think you
and I would probably agree is one of the
brightest minds and it's the least young
minds and in professionals out right now
no doubt and he agreed with everything
that I said and he talked about these
young men needing to know why needed to
be stimulated they interviewed DeAngelo
Hall who talked about you know the the
the modern athlete has more interest
than just football you know they have
more access to things outside of the
football world and so you have to be
able to harness their concentration when
they're in the building and then as a
quarterback you have to be able to make
sure they understand that there are some
extra things that they need to do after
they leave the building in order to be
prepared for
the next day or for the Sunday or Monday
or Thursday or Saturday came we have now
in the NFL right so that was my point I
know time and saying that Josh can't do
that he does do that for people that
would question his commitment question
his toughness question whether he loves
football
I've known him now for six years seven
years and in my mind there's no question
toughness this is a tough guy he's taken
some hits he's hung in there he keeps
coming back competitiveness look at the
Texas A&M game this year we would have
been blown out I mean absolutely blown
out had Josh Rosen not grabbed our team
and said listen compete like I compete
and then his love of football he stated
it I believe very eloquently is that if
I'm a young man of means which everyone
thinks I am and I don't know what means
is he says I don't and I am intelligent
I have a degree from UCLA and I can do
anything I want my dad's a doctor and
I'm committing a Wharton School of
Business and Lippincott publishing I
could do anything I want but I choose to
play football it's because I love it and
I think this rich is that everything
that he's done since high school at st.
John Bosco through UCLA is leading him
to his ultimate goal which is to go in
Super Bowls in the NFL and so I think he
gets it I'm fired up for the kid okay
and yet with the Browns on the clock you
think Sam Donald is a better fit fit you
know and and that's a hard one to
explain I go to a couple things here
I'll talk about Andy Dalton first you
know Andy Dalton plays the game to me
similar little similar in fashion to a
Sam Donald does and Hugh Jackson had a
lot of success with with Andy Dalton
that's why he's a head coach in
Cleveland
I believe that Sam and I look I haven't
talked to Sam about this and I do not
want to insult Sam but you know Sam
didn't get all the acclaim that Josh did
growing up he wasn't the number one
ranked player in the country so maybe
there's a little bit of an underdog
mentality buried deep in there that
maybe would benefit Cleveland so that's
that's what I met there you know for
certain players there's certain teams
that fit them and there's certain teams
that don't fit them and I think that
they that I think Josh would be wildly
successfully
but I think Sam's a really good fit
there well I mean you know I still think
josh is the best player the most NFL
ready player that I've ever been around
week one well I just want day one I'm
gonna tell you what you draft him put
him in the huddle as a starter the first
day
don't don't don't mess her please put
him in the huddle challenge him and he
will take the reigns and he will go and
I said you know I started this
conversation with you Jim Moore saying
how you've been part of this show since
the beginning what two years ago right
two years along this show when you said
that Rosen could be the number one
overall pick in the draft with Winston
and Mariota and no golf to in golf okay
do you mean those guys after Josh's
freshman year Jared Goff was was drafted
number one by the Rams turned out to be
a great pick I mean the guy is an
up-and-coming rising star and especially
with Sean there and now Jed fish missing
guys there and doing great things with
the Rams I made the statement I said I
believe that Josh Rosen was still would
have been the best quarterback in the
draft that year I'm not coming off of
that as great as Jared Goff has done I
still believe Josh at that time was the
most talent and he's only become more
town one of the things that really
benefited him this year was having Jed
fish who was our offensive coordinator
who has an NFL background was the
coordinators of Jacksonville Jaguars is
you know a guy that has real strong ties
with Bill Belichick able to kind of show
Josh what it's going to really take to
be an NFL caliber quarterback not just
from a physical standpoint but for all
the other things that you have to do to
be successful off the field
Jim Moore here and the Honda inside a
report brought to you by the Honda dream
garage spring event the best place to
leave winter is in your rearview mirror
get a great deal right now on the
versatile 2018 HRV the Honda dream
garage spring event is happening now at
your local Honda dealer back in 60
seconds I want to ask you what did John
do you think the Giants should do here
okay because you if you if you say darn
'old one let's just say that there's all
this talk now Josh Alan exactly what
Shivering Hewitt is it does and I just
want to know what you what you having
been in draft rooms as you've been and
been in situations that you have been
what is going on with the John stay at
home okay they had chubbin they had
Barclays and they've had Rosen and
they've had Mae
they've had them all essentially that's
next year with the gym mauro has been
also hanging out on path to the draft on
the NFL Network of of late as well back
in 60 seconds on the Rich Eisen show all
right another segment here with Jim Mora
who as I said has been hanging out on
the NFL Network this was like your third
stint pretty much for the NFL now what
is I literally feels like it's like
coming here like coming home I will
never forget when you interviewed Mike
Vick yeah you sat down and you told what
was the question you said it about the
the DVD if I put a you know a hundred
dollars in a DVD would you ever found it
I said no that was my first the first
interview I had ever done in my life
they asked me to do that and I said
anyone I said I'm a coach I don't know
how to do it but I went back there and
sat with him for over an hour and that
was the DVD it would have been the DVD
of gamfield preparing like say it was a
Tuesday a game tape to take her DVDs to
take home to study of your upcoming
opponent opponent right and if I put
money in there would you ever found it
no you know Mike played on instinct and
he had instincts he sure did the
question and again I guess that's part
of this whole issue here is that when
you see a talented kid and instincts are
are so apparent right and you see that
in an evaluation how do you know that
this kid is gonna be the one who doesn't
see the hundred dollar bill figurative
hundred dollar bill in the hypothetical
game film DVD I guess you you really you
go back and and NFL teams are doing this
right now and they're talking to high
school coaches they're talking to
college coaches they're talking to
guidance counselors they're talking to
if janitors right buddy they're going
every women true mand talking to the
equipment manager in your athletic
training room and talking to your
athletic trainers and how does he treat
people and how does react and coaches
how does he study because they want to
if you're gonna invest all this money
and a pic and a player you need to know
everything that you can possibly know
about him what do you think the Giants
are should do it to right now because
well I have so many options they have so
many options and and if Jared Allen were
to go number
one they've even got more options right
now because then the whole draft is
gonna go into a tizzy and it's gonna be
fun to watch because that means that
dark I know
because that means darn 'old would be
sitting there too and maybe the Giants
do love Josh Allen but not enough to
tell Eli that that the clock is ticking
faster than what's going on in his head
hmm I guess it does all start with the
evaluation of Eli Manning and the
evaluation of Davis Webb before you make
any maneuvers yeah what you see Eli what
what's your evaluation of him that he's
uh I think what the Saints did a while
back when they reloaded around drew
brees I think we might see something
like that you know like Eli's our guy
we're gonna take say Kwan Barclay well
we're gonna you know get the motherlode
hall and pick a whole bunch of guys can
help Eli take one more run at this thing
that's I mean I haven't been in the
draft room right but you know the next
two weeks they'll be sitting there for
hours and hours and hours going through
every scenario to be answering all the
unanswered questions they have about
prospects they'll be fielding calls from
everybody to set up possible trade
scenarios and they will be answering the
question that you just asked you know
are we going to put all of our faith in
Eli or are we gonna go draft a guy that
replaces Eli in a year or two and if we
draft a guy that replaces an a guy that
replaces Eli in a year or two are we
then doing the same thing that we did to
Eli last year which is undermining him
my gut feeling is that they'll probably
take say Kwan Barclay he's a great
player he's a guy that can help Eli he's
a guy that can help that defense that
struggled last year now they have anew
coordinators can do great things but
it's gonna be really for those first
five picks you know it's gonna be really
fun and the Browns as we know they have
two of the four and they can even go in
a lot of different directions well like
they couldn't move from four to two if
they want to do their quarterback in
Berkeley as well and give gentlemen
maybe some more picks in his back pocket
and all he's got to go down is drop to I
know and the Jets aren't gonna be the
one to call him up I don't know think I
don't think unless they do fall unless
darn 'old somehow does drop to two and
they love him it's motived Arnold drops
to three because I think we're all
assuming that josh is gonna go to the
Jets yes I do I do
think there's a possibility there and I
think if all of a sudden the Jets are on
the clock and they've got Josh and
they've got Sam they've got a situation
they probably didn't anticipate weeks
ago but not right now they are deep into
that discussion they are right yeah and
so for our fans listening and viewing
would well I was - Rosen know what I'm
saying is Gettleman
going in to draft night yes we'll have
already heard from Sandy the bills the
Broncos or anybody else that's totally
off the board yes and we'll know already
in his right-hand drawer what they're
offering right and then they'll go back
on a player who might be available a
suit that's all worked out it's worked
out and then they'll take those you know
those ten minutes and they'll they'll
just they'll all gather up the dish the
primary decision-makers and they'll say
oK we've made this decision are we all
good with it because as an organization
this has to be an organizational
decision that's the only way it's gonna
work it can't be Dave's decision it
can't be past decision has to be the the
mayor's decision to Tisha's decision it
has to be the New York Giants decision
and they will have made that decision
then they'll gather up and then you'll
making it you know well let's go to the
commissioner and Roger will step up and
have something to say and I'm sure it's
also four minutes left on the clock
say Bill's sweeten their offer which in
the bill because you know the bills are
sitting there and they're going okay
this is our offer to them right now but
let's let's keep this over here and if
they're balking at the last minute we'll
add it in and so there's going to be a
lot of drama and it's going to be really
fun just ten minutes and I can't well
I'm gonna be there at the draft will be
with Colton Miller and Josh are both
gonna be first-round picks so there's
nothing better than being there with
players that you had a chance to coach
and watching them realize their dream
and what was that what was that thing
you uh you wrote out for miles Jack when
he went oh yeah in Chicago you you you
you you wrote something I wrote him a
note
rich I wish I could remember that but I
was trying to manage his emotions you
know cuz he fell all the way through to
the second round it was you know we were
sitting at a table we thought we were
gonna go 5th and I knew that he probably
wasn't cuz Gus Bradley had said Jim we
have concerns about his knee and I tried
to prep miles for that and miles a kid
I've known since he was 12
you mean I love the guy you know and it
was painful to sit there with him so I'm
sitting there as you know as a an older
gentleman saying how can I help this
young man you know how can I help him
through this really difficult time his
life and so I did I had something that I
wrote to him was a saying or a quote and
I remember you had that in him and by
the way I mean he's now all in our and
that defense is filled with alpha males
we can fly down to the fire around the
football yeah and he's gonna get his
money that he didn't get in the first
round later on but with they had the
chance now to take jaylen Ramsey and
then they were able to go get Myles jack
right and you talk about to impact
players in their first two years have
completely transformed the way they
played defense I'm speaking of I guess
old guys in a way I don't mean to say
this how's your dad my dad is fantastic
a senior he's really good he's playing a
lot of golf he's working out he looks
healthy how old is it well he's uh he's
in his early 80s and his birthday is May
24th and he's spending a lot more time
in New Orleans Sean Payton has been so
gracious to you know kind of really
embraced my dad and keep him around the
team which I know that I appreciate
greatly because you know he's a lifer
he's a football lifer and the Saints
were a huge part of his of his career
and Sean has been so gracious do you
still wanna coach I do yeah I love to
coach I it's all I've really ever done
and I like doing the TV things that I'm
doing but I do want a coach I love the
impact you can have on young people I
love the competition I love the
adrenaline rush and I love to win I like
the the challenge of overcoming a loss
and I'd sure like to have another shot
at and I've learned a lot you know every
time you fail or you get fired or
something doesn't happen right if you if
you do a great job of self reflecting
and don't point the finger at others you
have a
chance to get better I think that's
happening so what you learned from your
time and what's what then I'm still
learning okay so it's still pretty fresh
yeah I'm still trying to really remove
the emotions from it and look at it
practically and you know what I needed
to do better and not point the finger
and say well they shouldn't fire me
that's that's not gonna help me at all
it's gonna help me is it look at myself
and say what can I do better and I'm
still doing that okay so you want to
coach college pro I just wanna coach I
love coaching and I did love coaching
college football and if there is a great
college job I take it and and because I
love the impact as I said you can have
on these kids you take some kids that
really you know there was a wall in
front of them it was gonna be hard for
them to hurt all over and you're able to
you know help them find a way to get
over that wall to their dream and that
doesn't necessarily play in the NFL but
it means you know a job a passion a path
to success and happiness and contentment
and you know it was just like a great
feeling when when these young men that
you were so invested in reach their
dreams it was like lash attack at the
draft yeah to care us you were there it
was yeah we had his we had the graph of
his so I was sitting with him in the
greenroom and kind of working the phones
between Dallas and Atlanta trying to get
one of them to take them take him
because they both liked him so I'd call
Dan Quinn and say Dan I just got off the
phone with Jason and they're gonna take
him and I called Jason I'd say Jason Dan
is gonna take him you know trying to
because I wanted to help tack and when
he was picked that that emotion that he
showed you remember dion interviewing
him and he looked through an f-bomb yeah
yeah it was like you know he had his
grandma's picture and he carried that
all night was he just passed away girl
she'd passed away when he was in high
school and I made her a promise on her
deathbed that he would be a first-round
draft pick and the great thing for me
was that the moment we got to spend
alone leaving the draft after all the
media stuff and everyone was at the
party and it was just tack and I in a
car going to the party and he's on his
phone and he's checking his Twitter and
he's Matt Ryan just you know direct
messaged me you know Julio Jones just
direct messaged me and he and they would
look at me go coach and tear I'm a
first-round draft pick and then he'd go
back and it was just it was
it was like I mean I got goose bumps
doing it you notice this is why we do
this for these kids at this point in my
life this is why we do it for these kids
eat stuff say hi to your dad for I will
see he's gonna be he's still doing
Saints games next yes yeah he loves it
that the best moment Mike played that
the best the best gym or when we have it
we have it always ready this was one of
those when they were Owen three you got
that over there my season is not over
when he started screaming at his [ __ ]
how about when he didn't know the mic
was live and he that really embarrassed
him you know my dad he doesn't like that
he says they're really embarrassed and I
told him I said dad that was a great
moment that was you that's what people
love is your authentic he's so
embarrassing snow it was people love you
dad because you are real authentic yeah
Jim always great having you um please
come back here any time you got it the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience